sujet extrêmement passionnant on va se
parler aujourd'hui des produits de Honor
on va regarder l'écosystème au nord
parce que vous le savez si vous suivez
vous le savez probablement sinon je vais
vous la prendre au nord est indépendant
de Huawei depuis maintenant que plus
d'un an et justement au nord à plein de
produits dans son catalogue et vachement
monter en gamme notamment au niveau des
smartphones avec le Magic 4 pro mais ça
on en a déjà parlé en début d'année là
on est plus sur le Honor 70 qui est
juste là et on va regarder comment
est-ce que tous ces produits
fonctionnent ensemble parce que étant
l'héritage de Huawei il y a une notion
d'écosystème vous allez voir que la
notion d'écosystème elle est très forte
ici avec plein de produits deviennent
communiquer les uns avec les autres qui
vous permet de venir les utiliser les
uns avec les autres notamment un magic
book 14 qu'on a ici j'ai son carton qui
est là qu'on va poser par terre qui va
communiquer avec le Honor 70 qui va
communiquer avec le Honor pas 8 vous
allez pouvoir utiliser vos écouteurs vos
irbuzz 3 pro avec tous les produits avec
du multipoint sans oublier bien
évidemment la montre connectée qui est
toujours le centre un peu indécent de
l'écosystème c'est la Watch GS3 regardez
hop là on va se la mettre ici pourquoi
et bien parce qu'elle vous permettra de
téléphoner et d'envoyer des messages de
faire plein de choses donc aujourd'hui
c'est une vidéo qui réalisait en
collaboration avec Honor aux normes a
dit tiens mon bon monsieur toi qui
connais quasiment tous nos produits
est-ce que tu pourrais expliquer comment
fonctionne l'écosystème de Honor le
montrer l'expliquer et comme moi je suis
impatienté que j'ai dit Go allez on y va
on est parti alors vous êtes prêt on y
va
le bloc de charge du magic book tac tac
tac hop là il va par terre le bloc de
charge assez de là la super charge au
nord du pad hop et va par terre on fait
un peu de place parce qu'il y a quand
même vachement de choses à montrer bon
je pense que la bonne du haut dans 70 on
s'en fout aussi un peu elle va par terre
je pense que la boîte du 8 on s'en fout
elle va par terre il nous reste quoi la
boîte des watch je vais la poser là la
boîte je l'ai airbodge je vais les poser
là et on va regarder tous ces jolis
produits alors regardez aujourd'hui on
va
bosser au poignet cinq produits
différents le magic book 14 version
Nvidia vous allez voir hyper hyper canon
on a le pas de 8 ça c'est la première
tablette de Honor arriver en France les
canons qui est aussi également ici on va
regarder et bien ces petits écouteurs
ici qui sont très cool multi-poux vous
allez voir pourquoi c'est super
intéressant et puis bien évidemment le
centre de l'écosystème c'est quoi et
bien c'est le smartphone on va regarder
le Honor 70 alors vous pouvez le faire
avec un autre smartphone que le Honor 70
mais si vous avez le Honor 70 ça ira
également très très bien et puis on va
regarder comment ça fonctionne alors on
va commencer par le smartphone parce que
c'est vraiment une fois de plus je vous
dis le centre de votre éco système alors
juste pour resituer le Honor 70 c'est un
smartphone qu'on connaît déjà on a ici
un capteur Sony mx800 qui est vachement
bien c'est un capteur de 50 mégapixels
le capteur captera plus de luminosité
notamment dans les conditions de nuit ça
c'est cool on a également 14-50
mégapixels qui fait ultra grand-angle
122 degrés plus macro et on a également
une caméra de selfie qui est planqué
juste ici de 32 mégapixel art je vous
passe un peu l'histoire je vous ai
notamment présenté un mode qui est à
part et qui est intéressant ici c'est le
mode solo cut il est super cool parce
que lorsque vous avez plusieurs
personnes et bien pour venir choisir de
filmer l'ensemble de la scène et de
filmer une seule personne en même temps
ça vous sort de fichier c'est très cool
son envie de faire la vidéo un peu
créative ou d'isoler quelqu'un dans un
groupe on peut le faire donc ça c'est
chouette vous avez également de la
recharge rapide 66 watts qui vous permet
de recharger à 60 % seulement 20 minutes
ça c'est très pratique lui s'est éteint
lui il m'a lâché c'est pas bien ça il y
a évidemment pour divertissement vous
avez un écran OLED diagonale de 6,67
pouces taux de rafraîchissement de 120
Hertz bref une bête de compète très bien
très confort très agréable il est cool
léger fin bon bref on peut l'emmener
partout facilement avec soi et lui
surtout c'est le cœur de votre
écosystème au nord c'est à dire que si
par exemple je viens prendre mon magic
book je vous montre ici par exemple
qu'est-ce que je peux venir faire il va
falloir que je me prenne une autre
caméra parce que là regardez je fais de
la gymnastique c'est pas la super idée
ce qui est très cool ici c'est que vous
voyez là j'ai ce qui m'appelle le Honor
magiclink ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que lorsque je prends mon smartphone et
que je viens le poser là mais en fait ça
me fait une copie de l'écran de mon
smartphone et ça c'est vachement cool
pourquoi parce que vous voyez quand je
bouge sur mon smartphone ça vient projet
directement là alors direz-vous à quoi
ça vous sert d'avoir ça comme ça et bien
en fait ça a vachement vachement
vachement d'intérêt ça veut dire que
lorsque je suis sur mon PC vous voyez
que j'ai ma petite souris et bien à deux
doigts hop je viens décaler et je viens
naviguer directement ici ce qui fait que
j'ai vraiment utilisé ici mon smartphone
à partir de mon pc prenons un exemple je
veux m'ouvrir j'en sais rien moi par
exemple une fenêtre naviguer sur
Internet je vais rechercher monsieur
gros je recherche monsieur greu ça me
propose différents trucs de Monsieur
Dreux et ça je veux le regarder d'un
côté je viens appuyer juste ici là et
hop ça me sort dans une fenêtre donc en
fait ça c'est très cool ça me permet
d'avoir une deuxième fenêtre donc là
j'ai cette fenêtre là où je vais avoir
mon navigateur Chrome directement dans
mon smartphone on reste bien dans mon
smartphone attention on n'est pas
ailleurs on est que dans le smartphone
et ensuite si par exemple les agences
syriens moi je vais regarder une vidéo
sur Youtube et bien je clique là je peux
plus la sortir parce que c'est deux
fenêtres max et vous le dites vous avez
atteint le nombre maximum de fenêtres ce
qui fait que c'est deux fenêtres de
votre Honor 70 plus une fenêtre
directement de votre PC donc ensuite ce
que je peux venir faire par exemple et
bien hop là vous voyez si je veux fermer
lui mais que lui je veux le sortir je
peux le sortir ce qui fait que ça me
permet d'avoir cette fenêtre là et ce
qui génial c'est qu'en plus de ça si par
exemple je vais dans ma galerie vous
voyez ici hop et que je veux la sortir
je clique ici sur le petit plus ça me
sort mes galeries directement et ben
regardez je vais avoir une icône en plus
qui est juste ici c'est cette icône là
qui va faire pivoter ma fenêtre et donc
là j'ai plus qu'à cliquer là et je
pivote comme ça donc si je regardais par
exemple mes photos sous un autre angle
et bien je peux le faire donc ce système
il est extrêmement pratique alors là je
vous montre un truc
truc qui est assez intéressant qui est
très marrant c'est au niveau du
copier-coller ça peut paraître tout bête
mais regardez par exemple je suis venu
chercher sur Bing un truc sur moi bon on
s'en fout c'est juste pour vraiment
montrer ici donc là je viens
sélectionner du texte je m'occupe
là allez on va jusque là Monsieur Greux
je fais comme d'habitude je vais faire
un petit clic droit pour copier donc ça
c'est facile et ensuite ce que je peux
venir faire je viens là par exemple je
vais sur mon bloc-notes voilà je
m'ajoute une note et là je me fais un
clic droit et là je me fais un petit
contrôle V pour coller donc là j'ai fait
un copier coller très facilement donc ça
c'est la première façon de faire mais il
y a également une autre façon de faire
vous connaissez le copier-coller hein
c'est très simple et donc là j'ai plus
qu'à venir directement là donc attendez
ça je vais tout effacer et en fait comme
mes objets sont connectés en permanence
avec un accès à un presse-papier et bien
j'ai qu'à laisser mon doigt appuyer ici
il me fait apparaître coller je n'ai
qu'à coller et j'ai mon texte parce que
j'ai mon presse-papier en fait on trouve
les deux donc ça c'est vachement
pratique également pour venir piloter
ici votre connexion vous passez par PC
manager alors regardez je vais venir
vous montrer PC manager parce que c'est
vachement bien fichu vous venez ici dans
votre PC manager que vous retrouvez
juste ici la collaboration avec mon
smartphone et là j'ai plusieurs options
donc là je suis en collaboration
multi-écran et je vois que j'ai
également ici un point d'accès i alors
en fait c'est un point d'accès Internet
ce qui fait que si je clique là je vais
venir utiliser la connexion internet de
mon smartphone sur mon pc donc mon
smartphone va servir de modèle pour mon
pc donc ça c'est vachement bien lorsque
je suis en déplacement et que j'ai pas
accès au wi-fi donc après je peux venir
désactiver ici le point parce que j'en
ai pas besoin je suis déjà sur un Wi-Fi
à la maison entre élément je peux venir
sauvegarder directement toutes mes
photos sur cet ordinateur sauvegarder
toutes mes vidéos sur cet ordinateur
alors puisqu'on se parle des photos et
des vidéos il y a un truc qui est aussi
très très cool c'est-à-dire que lorsque
je reprends ma collaboration multi-écran
ici je viens par exemple dans ma galerie
et dans ma galerie j'ai plein de photos
je vois par exemple cette photo là là
regardez hop là je l'ouvre coucou c'est
moi et bien en fait qu'est-ce que je
peux faire je peux venir la glisser
directement sur mon pc pour ce faire je
viens appuyer sur ma photo et dès que je
l'ai comme ça vous voyez en espèce
d'effet un peu comme si elle flottait et
bien je peux venir ici et je peux la
lâcher et elle va venir se copier
directement donc là je retrouve ma photo
je double clic et là ma photo est
directement sur mon pc et ça c'est
vachement cool donc je peux le faire
avec une photo je peux le faire avec de
la vidéo mais je peux encore aller
beaucoup plus loin je vous montre je
sors ici de mon application et je vais
par exemple dans mon application fichier
et dans fichier je vois quoi je vois que
j'ai un petit document PDF ça
m'intéresse je vais l'ouvrir et en fait
je veux l'ouvrir directement non pas
dans mon smartphone ici je vais l'avoir
directement sur mon pc c'est très facile
et une fois de plus il est dans mon
smartphone et bien regardez j'ai qu'à
double cliquer dessus et ça me l'ouvre
directement ici dans mon pc donc en fait
mon smartphone me servira de stockage
tout est toujours stocké ici mais pour
autant je peux le lire ici alors c'est
valable avec du PDF c'est valable avec
un Word avec un Excel bref c'est très
très cool et une fois que j'ai terminé
je vais cliquer ici et hop je le ferme
très facilement je peux venir faire la
même chose directement sur ma tablette
alors ici ma tablette c'est une patte 8
bah là pas d'huile en fait c'est la
première tablette de Honor qui est sorti
en France on a 8 haut-parleurs elles
sont spécialisés compatible DTS x on a
un écran de 12 pouces 1920 par 1200
alors on a un super rapport qualité-prix
parce qu'on est à peu près à 300 € ici
ça c'est cool et d'ailleurs si c'est
produit vous intéresse je vous mets un
lien en bas dans la description elle est
fine elle fait à peine 7 mm d'épaisseur
on est à quoi à 525 g ici on a une
grosse batterie de
7250 milliampères heure on peut venir
l'utiliser avec un stylet en Bluetooth
et on a l'écran qui est certifié
toveryland pour lutter contre la lumière
bleue donc on a une tablette qui est
pratique qui est complète qui ira bien
qui est très cool et en plus de ça qu'on
peut venir utiliser une fois de plus
avec tous l'écosystème au Nord alors
c'est ça qui vachement cool regardez
c'est exactement le même principe c'est
à dire que dans ma tablette regardez hop
je descends ici et là je vais avoir la
collaboration multi-écran donc je clique
là et là il va venir chercher les
appareils autour donc collaboration
multi-kranania ok j'accepte donc il faut
que le Bluetooth soit activé le wifi
soit activé moi j'ai mon smartphone qui
est à côté il le reconnaît ils me le
marque le pad hop je me connecte
connexion en cours autorisé d'un côté de
l'autre et là j'ai la collection qui est
établit comme je l'ai fait
exactement PC et bien je peux le faire
ici sur ma tablette ça me permet
effectivement et bien de tout venir
piloter ici directement depuis ma
tablette deux déplacer ma fenêtre si je
le souhaite et je pourrais faire la même
chose des copier-coller je pourrais
venir prendre des photos je pourrais
venir même les mettre directement dans
mon smartphone si je les ai dans ma
tablette je peux déplacer les documents
je peux faire beaucoup de choses et en
plus de ça est-ce qui est génial je peux
faire exactement sur ma tablette mais
également ici sur mon magicbook 14 c'est
à dire que je peux venir prendre les
appels sur ma pelle sur messenger sur ma
page sur WhatsApp je peux utiliser
directement la webcam de mon magic book
au lieu d'utiliser la caméra de selfie
de mon smartphone donc le truc est très
cool très complet et c'est ça qui est
vachement intéressant c'est que quel que
soit votre appareil je peux venir les
faire communiquer les uns entre eux en
fait je suis au nord vous avez ce qu'on
appellera Honor Connect qui va se
diviser en trois éléments le premier
c'est Honor share ou on vient de
partager les différents éléments voyez
on envoie un fichier du smartphone vers
le PC de la tablette vers le PC du PC
vers là où on veut bref on peut le faire
c'est très pratique par exemple ici
regardez je prends une photo hop là je
prends celle-là et là j'ai envie de la
partager très facilement et bien j'ai
qu'à cliquer sur Partager juste en bas
et là je vais voir les appareils qui
sont à proximité sur lesquels je peux
venir partager je vais retrouver bien
évidemment mon magic book mon Honor pas
de 8 mais également mon imprimante donc
si je veux venir imprimer très
facilement ici grâce à Honor recherche
je peux le faire et ça c'est cool
également on a également la
collaboration multi-écran où on vient
afficher l'écran de ton smartphone sur
son PC ou sur sa tablette et on a une
troisième partie qui est aussi vachement
bien qui s'appelle PC clone ça c'est
très cool c'est à dire que si vous avez
un PC d'une autre marque que vous voulez
changer de PC vous allez pouvoir venir
envoyer le contenu de votre vieux PC sur
votre nouveau PC très facilement grâce à
la fonction PC clone en fait c'est comme
vous le feriez sur votre smartphone très
facilement lorsque vous achetez un
smartphone vous venez cloner votre
ancien smartphone sur votre nouveau
smartphone et bien vous allez faire
exactement la même chose ici au niveau
de votre PC de Honor et ça c'est
chouette et il faut potentiel PC soit
sur Windows 10 soit sur Windows 11 ce
qui est très cool ici en plus c'est
qu'on a une version que la carte
graphique de Nvidia la GeForce RTX c'est
la 2050 alors elle permettra de jouer à
des jeux en 1080p alors on est ici sur
une carte graphique milieu de gamme on
est sur un i5 donc on peut faire tourner
les jeux les plus puissants les jeux les
plus gourmands les jeux les plus
performants mais il faut faire tourner
quand même pas mal de jeux et pour tout
ce qui va être bureautique et usage
voyez collaboratif avec différents
produits que ce soit une tablette ou un
smartphone on peut y aller facilement en
plus de ça ici vous avez un écran de
2,5k à l'intérieur ça c'est très cool
Corning aurillacus ici le format c'est
un 3 demi ce qui est cool par rapport au
16/9 c'est que le 16/9 il va s'arrêter
par la 3/2 vous en avez un petit peu
plus en bas ça c'est vachement bien pour
tout ce qui va être productivité
notamment vous avez en plus de mode de
fonctionnement ici vous avez un mode de
fonctionnement équilibré qui va vous le
brider à 50 watts vous appuyez sur FN et
p comme ça vous passez sur un mode 50
watts ou vous venez économiser de la
batterie vous allez un peu moins loin en
fait au niveau de la performance et
lorsque vous l'avez bronzé sur le
secteur et vous avez plus de 20% de
recharge vous refaites la même manip FN
et P et là vous allez passer sur un mode
avec un peu plus de performance 70 watts
ça va booster davantage lorsque vous
voulez venir notamment jouer à des jeux
un peu plus gourmands et bien évidemment
ici vous avez du wifi 6 ça c'est cool
mais alors Palace ce sont des écosystème
parce que je vous en parlais vous avez
également une montre alors la boîte elle
est juste là on se parle ici de la Honor
watch GS3 elle est cool pourquoi parce
que elle vous permet de répondre à vos
appels directement depuis votre montre
vous allez avoir également vos messages
et puis surtout vous avez plein de modes
pour le sport vous laissez appuyer vous
choisissez vos cadran il y en a
énormément moi j'aime bien celui-là je
trouve assez joli c'est très clair c'est
le cadran coloré vous venez naviguer
pour voir ce que vous avez fait vos
battements cardiaques le plus haut le
plus bas le stress votre lecteur de
musique votre activité du jour et vous
revenez au début vos réglages là vos
notifications et ici vous voyez vos
différentes applications ici vous avez
104 modes de sport pour venir vous
entraîner c'est vraiment une montre pour
les sportifs les amateurs du sport mode
Entraînement course guidée fitness et
compagnie si ça c'est très très complet
et en plus de ça si vous voulez suivre
votre rythme cardiaque votre SpO2 ou
tracez votre sommeil vous pouvez le
faire niveau de stress également les
exercices respiratoires la météo
l'alarme le chronomètre bref elle est
très cool le seul petit bémol ici c'est
que vous n'avez pas de catalogue
d'applications donc on peut pas venir
ajouter
différentes applications notamment comme
par exemple Spotify c'est pas possible
ça c'est vraiment un héritage de Huawei
donc je pense que dans le temps ça va
venir bouger ils vont faire évoluer leur
montre pour avoir un catalogue
d'application mais pour l'envoyer ce
n'est pas possible alors elle est déjà
très complète comme elle est là boussole
baromètre en même temps chez compagnie
météo mais voyez on peut pas venir en
mettre plus c'est le bémol mais écoutez
positif ici c'est que vous avez 14
vous voulez une très grosse autonomie
c'est en tout cas ici tout l'avantage
que vient nous proposer cette montre
connectée et après le
dispensable d'un écosystème il y a ce
sont les scooter ici on est sur les
herbeus 3 pro ils sont très cool petite
étui vous venez vous les sortez alors ce
que j'aime bien c'est que sur ces
écouteurs regardez vous glissez votre
doigt vous montez le son comme ça là
vous voyez au niveau de la tige vous le
montez vous le baissez play pause
morceau suivant morceau précédent et on
vient bouger directement là donc ça
c'est vachement cool et surtout ce qui
est très bien ici à l'intérieur on va
voir un double haut-parleur coaxial on
va avoir un driver de 11 mm pour les
basses et un Twitter en céramique piezo
électrique pour les aigus rien que ça
alors vous avez une annulation de son
intelligente avec trois niveaux plus un
mode automatique on a en plus de la
charge rapide en 5 minutes de charge
vous êtes reparti pour 2h d'autonomie ça
c'est cool et surtout ce qui nous
intéresse ici c'est la connexion multi
point pourquoi et bien parce que par
exemple je me regarde un truc sur ma
tablette par exemple je mets un peu de
musique donc là j'ai de la musique
directement sur Youtube pendant ma tête
vous vous l'entendez pas et ensuite je
vais reprendre et je vais mettre de la
musique ici on va se mettre sur Spotify
et hop j'arrête ici je viens reprendre
ici et ici je l'ai directement dans mes
oreilles donc le truc est vachement bien
c'est que si je regarde une série hop on
m'appelle je peux récupérer ici
directement dans mes écouteurs ou
écouter la musique bref je peux le faire
c'est très facile ça c'est la connexion
multi points et elle est vachement cool
et je peux le faire également ici bien
évidemment avec mon magic book au nord
est une marque qui se développe avec de
plus en plus de produits un écosystème
qui est très complet avec je vous dis
beaucoup beaucoup de produits qui
arrivent au catalogue une marque qui
s'étoffre alors le truc qui est
vachement cool si vous voulez c'est que
ils ont un vrai savoir-faire qui est
extrêmement bien maîtriser moi les Magic
books je les connais je les trouve très
sympa très canon sont des jolis
ordinateurs pas forcément trop chaud ça
défend lequel on va venir choisir mais
qui reste vraiment abordable on a aussi
une gamme qui est très large au niveau
des smartphones avec plein de
fonctionnalités qui sont super
intéressantes surtout un très joli
savoir-faire de belles finitions et d'un
point de vue logiciel aussi ça
fonctionne bien donc ça c'est aussi très
très cool et c'est un truc qui me plaît
bien j'adore tout cet héritage qui vient
effectivement de Huawei parce que ça
très clairement c'est l'héritage de
Huawei maintenant la limite un peu du
truc c'est que des fois on voit qu'il y
a deux trois trucs qui devraient encore
évoluer notamment au niveau de la montre
j'attends d'avoir un catalogue
d'applications ici pour pouvoir venir
ajouter différentes apps donc ça c'est
le truc qui j'espère arrivera plus tard
peut-être sur d'autres montres en tout
cas comme elle est là elle est déjà très
bien et si on veut aller dans
l'écosystème alors c'est cohérent de
venir à la choisir et puis le dernier
petit point de détail si je voulais
vraiment chipoter chipoter pour chipoter
c'est que
lorsque je viens ici dans la
collaboration multi-écran et bien il y a
deux trois petites mises à jour Software
qui devrait être faites notamment la
collaboration tablette qui aujourd'hui
n'existe pas qui existait chez Huawei je
sais pas si elle a existé ici ça ça
vient un peu de l'héritage qu'on avait
avant avec Huawei mais ce que je trouve
super intéressant c'est de voir cette
marque qui je vous le dis encore c'est
il y a un an et demi à peu près a pris
son indépendance c'est émanciper de
Huawei récupérer les services Google et
il y a une solution extrêmement complète
à 360 degrés et tous vos produits
communiquent les uns avec les autres
vous l'avez vu ce soir le smartphone
avec la tablette avec l'ordinateur ça
fonctionne vachement bien donc si vous
avez besoin de faire communiquer vos
produits entre eux vous avez de quoi
faire je vais penser notamment j'en sais
rien moi des étudiants qui vont shooter
comme ça qui vont ensuite prendre des
notes qui vont ensuite les mettre dans
le PC ou dans la tablette à la maison
pour venir travailler si vous êtes par
exemple amoureux de photos que vous
venez shooter des photos vous prenez par
exemple votre Magic 4 Pro vous avez des
fichiers RAW vous les mettez directement
sur votre magic book directement dans
Lightroom vous éditez vous fichiers RAW
directement là vous venez les partager
je trouve ça vachement bien donc une
fois de plus c'est une solution qui est
extrêmement complète elle est pas
parfaite elle est complète elle est
vachement bien et on a un très jolie
écosystème de marque à vous de me dire
vous ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires est-ce que vous avez des
produits au nord est-ce que vous avez
des produits du nouveau Honor du Honor
indépendant du Honor qui arrive avec des
produits encore plus haut de gamme et je
voulais montrer il y a pas longtemps au
nord continue d'étoffer sa gamme avec un
smartphone qui se plie qu'on verra
arriver l'année prochaine en France
probablement vers le mois de février
donc abonnez-vous c'est pas déjà le cas
comme ça on en reparlera ensemble à vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez une
fois de plus en bas dans les
commentaires et nous on se retrouve très
bientôt et une fois de plus une fois de
plus si un de ces produits vous
intéresse je vous mets un lien juste en
bas allez jeter un coup d’œil allez
visiter la boutique du Honor vous allez
voir les produits sont très cool bisous
à bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]